music seems to be the biggest thing
we're expecting and it's you know a very
crowded market already so what can we
really expect well that's the big
question mark really is what can Apple
do that's really different and distinct
when we think about these music services
there's not a huge difference in the
library of music available so it boils
down to sort of the secondary things how
you package it how you put it together
how you discover music all of those
things become more important and you
know will they have djs on channels and
things like that to kind of bring some
kind of new life to this music service
so that's the you know the big question
mark is what can they do to really
distinguish themselves from like you
said the very strong competition and we
also thought there might be something
about TV but it seems like that's not
gonna happen no everything we're hearing
is that unfortunately the TV thing is
going to take them much longer they
can't get the contrast together I mean
in the long run I think they're doing
the right thing but they need to get
local channels for local sports and
things like that and that's what people
want before I think they're gonna cut
the cord and so unfortunately that's
gonna take apples bet on TV has been a
long time in the making Josh you know
talked about it before he passed away
what about updates to health kick home
kit watchkit I was he got my watch but
yes I was gonna comment on that soft
pink pants I just have to point out I
think that's gonna be the big news I
mean it's a developer conference just
like build is for Microsoft and I o is
for Google this is about getting their
developers excited about building apps
for their ecosystem and platform and you
know they talked a lot big picture wise
around home kit last year then they
recently started talking about health
kid obviously they talked about watch
kit I think they need to flesh those
visions out and so I expect the big news
is going to be around how you know they
can do more with home kit how it's going
to integrate what kind of products are
going to be available what they could
potentially do with health kit how you
can do better faster apps with you know
Apple watch and you know a lot of the
early apps people are saying all they're
really slow and they don't do a lot part
of the challenges because developers
didn't have full access to the device
what about cars in horse right a lot of
excitement about cars we got a little
hint
an apple executive at the code
conference a couple of weeks ago that
they're interested exactly and it's a
huge area and and the other big question
that i have is will we start to see
apple finally do this kind of the own
app their Apple version of IOT right
because they have all the different
pieces with home and health and fitness
and car but they haven't really told the
whole story about all of that stuff
coming together so one ? i have is will
we start to see them talk about things
like a digital identity service that
allows you to move across services and
devices and cars and everything all
unified through some kind of Apple
identity service that would be
interesting now we're also expecting
updates to the mobile operating system
OS 10 no hardware no hardware I don't
you that's the one that's the general
sense of it so in the grand scheme of
WWDC s how much does this one matter I
mean what what will be important I think
this is more of a refinement year you
know it's more about and it's there's
sort of a yin and yang with WWDC s
there's some years you've got the big
you know announcements do products a lot
of things happening this year seems more
like all right we talked about a lot now
we're gonna flush it out we're gonna
refine it we're gonna make it better and
they're doing a number of things like
that that I think are gonna be more
subtle so the end result is the news
result is a little bit on the lower side
than previous year